بعد عشر سنوات على مقتله
عاد العقيد ليظهر على الشاشة، لكن كيف؟
تسجيل نشرته قناة الحدث،،
فما هي مشاعر ابنه سيف الإسلام وابنته عائشة
بل وما هي ردة فعل باقي أفراد أسرته؟
وما مغزى نشر هذا المقطع الصوتي بعد هذه المدة؟
وهل يعود سيف الإسلام بهذا لتعود روح القذافي للبلاد؟
وهل يحقق سيف الإسلام حلم والده
بقيادة الوطن إلى بر الأمان؟...
في تسجيل له قبل القبض عليه قال العقيد:
لأول مرة، إنه "سوف يقوم بعملية اقتحام
لكسر حصار مدينة سرت"،
متوقعا مقتله في تلك المعركة
دفاعا عن العروبة، والإسلام، والمبادئ، والقيم، والعدالة
في مواجهة العدوان والظلم".
سأقوم هذه الليلة
بعملية اقتحام لكسر حصار مدينة سرت
ويقول العقيد معمر القذافي أيضا،
إن 40 دولة قامت بالعدوان على ليبيا،
في ظل صراع دام 40 عاما من أجل الحق والعدل والكرامة،
في وجه قوى البغي والعدوان،
مشيرا إلى أن سقوط العاصمة الليبية طرابلس
في يد قوات حلف الناتو والجماعات الإرهابية المتأسلمة،
كان نتيجة خيانة.
ودعا زوجته صفية، وابنته عائشة إلى الفرح والسعادة
لأنه مقدم على الموت بكل شجاعة وإيمان،
مؤكدا أنه يفتخر ببلاده أمام العالم.
بعد ظهور هذ التسجيل الصوتي ظهر نجله سيف الإسلام،
وبظهوره ظهرت رغد صدام حسين فماذا قالت؟
بعد إعلان ترشحّه للانتخابات وجهت ابنة صدام رسالة لابن القذافي
إليكم نصها:
"أخي الغالي سيف الإسلام القذافي
نترقب باهتمام كبير أنا وكل محبيك المرحلة القادمة".
وأضافت رغد صدام "دعائي لكم بأن تعودوا إلى المكانة التي تليق بكم
وتخدموا ليبيا وتعيدوها لموقعها الحقيقي".
فهل تشكل رغد وكل أتباع ومحبي صدام حسين
دعما إضافيا لابن القذافي للمضي قدما في استعادة أمجاد والده؟
لكن ماذا عن شقيقة سيف الإسلام وأقرب الناس إليه بعد وفاة والده؟
عائشة القذافي التي كانت اليد اليمنى لأبيها،
وقفت وستقف مع شقيقها ليعيد ما فقده الشعب بعد وفاة العقيد،
فماذا صنعت عائشة؟
بعد إعلان سيف الإسلام ترشحه لم تتأخر عائشة كثيرا
وأصدرت بيانا للشعب الليبي كافة تقول فيه:
إلى أبناء وطني الغالي، إلى حرائر ليبيا أمهات وأخوات وشقائق الشهداء والرجال،
إلى من أوصى بكن والدي في شهادته، وكل شريفات الوطن وماجداته
فقد آن الأوان أن ينجلي ليل الذل والمهانة بصبح يعيد صفاء الحياة
وينتشل ليبيا من وحل الدنس والنهوض بها مجدداً".
عائشة استخدمت تعبيرات والدها ولكن على طريقتها الخاصة،
وقالت: لقد دقت ساعة الحقيقة،،، نعم فلقد حان الوقت
ليعلن الشعب الليبي عن قائده الذي سيقوده في المرحلة القادمة،،
وذّكرت عائشة الليبيين أن سيف الإسلام لم يغادر البلاد
على الرغم أن الموت كان يحيط به من كل مكان،
بل إنه رفض كل المغريات للخروج من البلاد وظل صامدا يحمل قضية ليبيا في قلبه،
واختتمت ابنة العقيد بيانها :
"إنني وقد دقت ساعة الحقيقة أخاطب شرفاء الوطن
بعدم التقاعس في التوجه لمراكز الاقتراع..
فأصواتكم وسيلتكم الوحيدة لخلاص ليبيا اليوم وغدا..
فصوتك إذا لم تستخدمه لصالحك يستخدمه غيرك ضدك".
....
وكانت ليبيا في أواخر ٢٠١١
قد أعلنت مقتل زعيمها معمر القذافي،
موضحة أنه لجأَ إلى أنبوب صرف كبير مع عدد من الحراس الشخصيين،
لكن قوات المحتجين المدعومة من التحالف وقتها
عثرت عليهم وفتحت النار صوبهم وأصابته بالرصاص الحي في ساقه،
ولم تكتف القوات باعتقال العقيد جريحا مصابا،
بل سارعت إلى تصفيته و التنكيل بجثته،
لعلمها بشعبية العقيد الكبيرة إذ لو ظهر مجددا فقد يستعيد أنصاره المبادرة
ويعود ليكمل مسيرته بتطهير البلاد من الخونة والمرتزقة،
فهل جاء الدور الآن على ابن العقيد سيف الإسلام
، ليكمل ما تركه والده ناقصا؟...
وهل يشكل دعم رغد صدام حسين وعائشة القذافي وأتباعهما
رفدا قويا لسيف الإسلام ليقود البلد بعد أن رحل والده؟....
أسئلة ستكون الإجابة عليها الأيام القادمة في أرض الواقع لليبيين....
...
ستجدون التسجيل الصوتي كاملا للعقيد معمر القذافي
برابط في صندوق الوصف...
..
إذا أعجبكم الفيديو لا تنسوا الإعجاب به والاشتراك بالقناة
وتفعيل الجرس لنستمر بالمزيد إن شاء الله